mathieu pour julien julien baronne 32
ans s'apprête ce matin à les donner à
manger aux lémuriens
là on est chez les makis cattas sont des
lémuriens est ce que je fais
généralement quand j'arrive le matin
c'est qu'on va procéder à un premier
nourrissage ça nous permet de nous en
tant que soigneur de pouvoir regarder si
tous les individus du groupe vont bien
s'il n'a pas de blessure
les lémuriens mange des légumes le matin
et des fruits le soir le soigneur leur
donne quelques compléments alimentaires
goût framboise chaque il est attribué à
une espèce sont des loges qui sont
chauffés à l'intérieur ils ont à
disposition de la nourriture et de l'eau
ils ont un accès donc actuellement en
pleine saison quand il fait chaud on
leur laisse ce qu'on appelle un accès
libre et quand les températures vont
commencer à baisser puisque ce sont des
animaux qui viennent de madagascar ils
n'ont pas forcément l'habitude des
températures très froides hivernale le
soigneur du soir sera chargé lui de
rentrer les individus c'est pour ça donc
du coup que à thoiry on a une division
on a les soigneurs du matin et les
soigneurs du soir le soigneur muni de sa
cisa et coupe des branches de bambou
pour une autre espèce de lémurien se
sont tour des lémuriens qui ont
l'habitude dans le milieu naturel de
consommer du bambou dont qu'ils adorent
ça ces lémuriens plus timides sont
abrités dans un second bâtiment e de
caractère on les connaît parce qu'ils
sont très méfiants très peureux et du
coup ici mes filles et sont en même
temps tentée par le bon bout on essaye
de les habituer à l'extérieur 80% du
travail du soigneur animalier est
consacrée au nettoyage des enclos une
tâche en extérieur qu'ils apprécient
puisque avant d'être soigneurs
animaliers
il était assistant logistique dans un
entrepôt de fret aérien à roissy
c'est aussi ça le métier on va on va
c'est un métier qui est assez physique
on travaille à l'extérieur faut pas
avoir peur univers d'avoir froid et il
était d'avoir chaud c'est une
reconversion professionnelle pour julien
il a découvert ce métier à travers des
bénévolat j'étais je pense un peu âgés
pour faire les écoles
du coup je me suis tourné vers une
formation
à domicile qui va en fait vous fournir
les cours vous êtes suivi par un
professeur mais à distance et qui va
donc vous fournir aussi des conventions
pour les stages c'est ce qui est super
important chez un soigneur c'est
l'expérience
après plusieurs stages dans des parcs
julien a débuté comme soigneur au zoo de
thoiry en juin une reconversion
professionnelle bénéfique pour le
trentenaire
ça n'a pas été un chemin facile mais il
faut s'accrocher
et puis on y arrive il y a deux équipe
de soigneurs julien fait partie de
l'équipe du matin ils se retrouvent avec
sa collègue pour faire le point sur
leurs journées le reste du temps le
soigneur a toujours son talkie walkie
pour échanger avec ses collègues ils
sont particulier parce que ce sont des
talkie walkie qui une fois allongé vont
sonner et donc si on a un incident
quelque part dans le parc et qu'on se
retrouve au sol avec la jambe cassée par
exemple le tall qui va sonner surtout
chez tout le monde et donc du coup ils
peuvent nous retrouver comme ça ils
savent qu'une alerte les soigneurs
s'occupent également des animations les
visiteurs prennent place à bord du
safari
on va donc accueillir les visiteurs les
faire monter dans le camion et partir
pour une petite heure et demie
les visiteurs peuvent découvrir des
lions des éléphants et d'autres animaux
durant cette visite en compagnie de
julien en france seulement trois écoles
prépare au métier de soigneur animalier